you may remember on our very first
episode we talked about the election in
India well after five long weeks and
over 500 million votes on Friday there
was an announcement
it appears at 9:37 a.m. and we are
calling the election the BJP would have
won the election and not in remotely
with these numbers should not find it
difficult to be the next prime minister
of India whoa that is a seizure-inducing
amounts of information on that screen if
you follow this indian election you
learn two key things one a renter Modi
was destined for a historic victory and
two no one covers an election like
Indian news networks who are apparently
sponsored by a dural we look at it we
are not speeding this footage up I feel
like I'm playing a slot machine in a
Mumbai casino while high on peyote and
so just a small word of advice to Indian
news networks this is not the most
relaxing way to watch television the
only thing that this is good for is
potentially putting your elderly viewers
in the hospital